it is the perversion of language in
barcelona
rupture i was born
don't forget me not the issue is that it
really is more they also say to
compare them we govern critics or some
politicians sometimes on board by their totalitarian amorin people
started to start the
same work is the same  tarot
terrorism is indecent and also
demonstrate the low vision and
low political height of being
journalists and certain politicians
I have been an independentista since I was a
teenager very few generations
can be able to consign an
Orlando republic it is a feeling they do not see it was
positive because dignity  and the
community and really the zero transformation
like the second world war
and
the relationship that encourages you this presentation
is a relationship already linked to the family the
family
and at güidi hours always in
sentimental tribute to that of Spain but long
before
inda pan de edad and in  own language in
own culture culture
in two or three dead people
found by frank  ism of our
clear false family the shrink freedom and
democracy to defend freedom and the
impression so we are the family for
pardilla also any loss the same
is also prisoner
of receiving this company
and the
same also to reinforce
foreign power and to be able to vibrate  normality
that seeing the unfair way will also
have the change advisor they will work for us
but we are on time
the war has started to last but at that
moment we were braver than
us and they are going to start
abu dhabi will be worth the Catalan dignity
and the  extra control filter
for a copy spanish exhibition
although it is a parody the one that palencia
alar the muse of who prepared the
symbolism that is the theme they will carry
packages that it is an outdated and spanish transit
what is a perfect catalan problems
that it is precisely at this time only
some unfair and it's like feeling yauhar they
also threw a lot of things in
the family's work friends but  or they also
know that it is a reason for strength and
how much 200 someday that these
animal tables the mastery that these other
than the most difficult things
wherever this illusion with the activity will
distribute gave to continue working
this is my mind asbert of bulky
exception of  football and the tics although
I throw Havana which is the successful one but
obviously if the majority in the end the
world where first regarding this
decision and continue working this
declines in their policies from
democracy to achieve at another
time comes in the plural no
shooting bani and also a book
in a larger and heavier strip carles
verd independent
well it's already in the cinema
I have our country catalonia don't
kill yourself the strait what is the other
european country that can be seen
lanka the cinema is on  write down films in
catalan when they have the new
spanish government with generic used public
of the pond we would be respecting
televisions m  arianito separation because
in Spanish like the Spanish notes
carla oligarchy the structure that he
forms politically is not I do not understand that
there are different nations that the country the
state and politics always help
assimilation does not give to whose integration
other cultures will have and in trying to
federalism with  federalism,
autonomism and not an assortment of fines in
which it will advance to the list that was
autonomist lleras a panties is there
because it was impossible
carmona
lippi
cardona
and look at the number of citizens due to
injury
and these people who went to vote were
2 million people the body are
Catalans are 7 million Catalans
and Spaniards are 48 million two
million people they cannot modify
the constitutional and territorial framework of
a country of 48 million people they
cannot they do not have enough strength
that the claim is also illegal
but anyway  It is that they are not
majorities in the
movement, although it is very serious
after 30 years of n  nationalism in
Catalan schools after a
campaign that has lasted 30 years
investing in education in money
under a patronage regime and in the
media after all that time they
have managed to rise to 47
percent now we must
convince part of that 47%  that it is better to be in
a reformed spain than in a
catalonia outside of spain and europe
and justin long island records
great because they help to calculate
friendships bedrooms music and also
know how to tremble and break the antenna we are
positive
where now to who here I  I hope the one
I decided is that somehow
neither the strength nor the
resistance counts for us to be able to achieve
independence and that it follows a way that is at
least traumatic, possible, love mathematics,
what happens,
tics,
no